il met en 78 et là ce qui est
hallucinant c'est que encore aujourd'hui
quand on en parle toutes les rumeurs
courtes personne ne veut croire qu'un
homme on va dire extraordinaire et une
mort ordinaire j'ai encore lu je suis là
pour préparer il y en a encore qui
disent que il y a eu de la drogue il y a
peut-être une assassinat un suicide
parce qu'il avait 39 ans qui commençait
à vieillir et qu'il avait très très peur
de la vieillesse qui est venu devenir
ridicone est-ce que tout simplement il
est venu
en même temps ça appartient au star des
bavardages quand il faut pas mourir dans
son lit il faut mourir d'une manière
étrange
ouais mais il y a eu beaucoup de
bavardages oui mais Claude François
personne n'y croyait en même temps il y
a eu deux phénomènes il avait l'habitude
de mettre sa vie privée et ses accidents
qu'il avait eu tout le long de sa
carrière en lumière ce soir quand on lui
a tiré dessus en 77 quand il allait à
bondultes en 75 quand il y a une action
de voiture etc donc tout le monde est
habitué on dit ça y est il a monté un
coup il a dit qu'il était mort et c'est
et tout le monde a pensé ça alors
pas du tout non non il était chez lui il
s'est levé à 13h 14h à Michel Marie il
était
13h15 parce que j'ai le détail précis du
rapport de police il était rentré la
veille de les uns à 13h il se réveille
ça va tranquille il téléphone à son
chauffeur à sa mère Rémy grimba qui
réalisait les rendez-vous dimanche pour
Michel Drucker
il appelle il donne des consignes il y
avait son attaché de presse qui était là
Marie-Thérèse à l'époque et puis
Kathleen sa fiancée et puis il leur
prépare un petit déjeuner c'est-à-dire
de la purée d'avocat sur des toasts j'ai
et à un moment donné et à 14h10 il
rentre dans la salle de bain il dit je
prends une douche parce qu'il avait pris
un peu les rayons du soleil il s'était
mis un peu nulle solaire je vais enlever
ça il prend simplement une douche et un
moment donné il voit l'applique qui a
dévié de un demi centimètre la pique en
cuivre et là et chaque fois qu'il
rentrait dans sa douche il voyait cette
applique il met il faisait un petit
geste avec deux doigts pour la dresser
parce qu'il était très maniaque très
précis et c'est le souci du détail qu'il
a tué quelque part et il a fait une fois
de trop il l'a fait une fois de trop il
est resté collé à l'applique évidemment
il a fait ce qu'il ne faut jamais faire
quand on prend le courant c'est à dire
qu'on met l'autre main pour se dégager
ce qui fait qu'on fait un circuit fermé
à partir de là c'est foutu incroyable
donc c'est sa fiancée Kathleen qui l'a
attrapé heureusement souvent quand il y
a un électrocuté il y en a deux parce
que un autre cours pour le défendre et
on prend aussi le courant d'accord comme
elle était isolée avec des sabots de
bois elle a arraché
en 78
et oui c'est une très grande école et
c'est incroyable elle a été sauvée grâce
à ça elle a elle a elle a allongé dans
le couloir les pompiers sont arrivés
très très vite seulement les ceux du
c'est le 15e qui est arrivé pas le 16e
ils étaient sur un incendie ah non c'est
très compliqué il y a tout un tas
d'éléments neuvième étage les pompiers
montent les étages à suivre ils ont
tenté toutes les réanimations et il est
possible et un moment donné à
14h45 précises c'était fini c'était fini
d'accord très bien donc effectivement il
meurt au point même que des fans il y
avait tellement de fans il y a une fan
qui s'est jetée d'un pont et qui est
morte c'est pour vous dire à quel point
c'était alors il avait un sacré
caractère on va en parler dans dans un
instant mais comme on a tous François
Junior qui était avec nous priorité et
Dieu sait si je suis très très bonjour
très heureux ou j'ai regardé là très
heureux de vous avoir merci beaucoup
merci beaucoup j'ai beaucoup
d'admiration pour votre père et je
précise que je ne voilà et je précise
que je ne juge rien du tout du tout et
que et voilà je pose juste des questions
c'est vrai que pour les 45 ans
malheureusement de sa mort ressortent
des mauvaises des mauvaises histoires et
j'aimerais que vous y répondiez des
histoires comme quoi effectivement bah
il était fan de de gamine en fait on a
je vais être plus sincère on a un sonore
de RTL de lui à l'époque j'aimerais que
vous l'écoutiez et que vous le
commandiez
alors moi je sais que je correspond à
une catégorie de filles d'un certain âge
il se trouve que par bonheur ça sent la
même catégorie des filles hypertendus
passionnés ça représente cette espèce de
foule de folie qui a entre 14 et 18 ans
et puis je suis obsédé pendant catégorie
de filles qui vient me voir je vais te
dire c'est même si ça peut paraître
physique parce que bon dit bon tu aimes
les fruits verts des petites filles dès
qu'elles ont 15 à 18 ans après 18 ans
c'est des vieillards on en parle plus
alors je dis c'est un petit peu ça et en
fait c'est le contraire j'aime ou
jusqu'à 17 18 ans après je commence à me
méfier dieu seul sait si j'ai des
aventures au-delà de 18 ans bien sûr
heureusement mais après 18 ans je me
méfie parce que les filles commencent à
réfléchir elles sont plus naturelles etc
ça commence même quelquefois avant elle
devient plus cette espèce de de rêve que
représente pour moi la fille c'est à
dire cette espèce de choses instinctive
comme ça quand les filles piquent des
crises etc je les trouve non civilisés
mais exactement comme je les aime bien
sûr je le reprécise je l'ai déjà dit
mais j'adore cette phrase on ne juge pas
les lois d'aujourd'hui
les faits d'aujourd'hui avec les lois
d'hier donc il aucun jugement et surtout
de ma part Claude François Junior merci
beaucoup c'est juste que ça ressort
peut-être pour des mauvaises raisons des
mauvais journalistes je voulais avoir
votre réaction
alors je suis désolé parce que je ne
vous entends pas du tout ça m'étonne un
petit peu que ça marche quand même mais
est-ce que ça marche
mais vous roulez faudrait vous arrêter
quand même il est au passager
en gros c'est une interview
de 1967
on va vous appeler
on va on va vous appeler et raffinez il
n'y a aucun piège
Fabien et du coup puisqu'on est là
dessus Fabien effectivement il est
accusations sur ma balle monsieur
et comment il s'appelle
merci d'être avec nous merci Claude
François c'est bizarre mais c'est Claude
bonsoir
au moins vous avez beaucoup d'humour
mais vous avez beaucoup d'humour mais
pardon ça fait bizarre de dire Claude
François mais voilà encore une fois vous
avez toutes toutes mon écoute et je le
redis et je le reprécise je ne juge pas
du tout c'était une autre époque je veux
juste votre quand tout ça ressort tout
ce qu'on ressort sur votre paire
aujourd'hui pour ces 45 ans je voulais
votre avis
et ça ressort depuis des années déjà
Mathieu en réalité et en fait je trouve
ça scandaleux et ça juste parce que il
n'est plus là pour me défendre et parce
qu'en plus la loi ne me permet pas de
pouvoir faire des procédures en
diffamation et donc tout le monde peut
impemment dire raconter calomnier
colporter et c'est exactement ce qui se
passe il est mon père est associé
la pédophilie lorsque c'est donc ça
revient à le mettre dans le même sac
même ça que Marc dutrousse qui est juste
encore une fois ce qu'on a vu je vous
invite à regarder la définition du mot
pédophilie et on est impuissant voilà
donc en fait
il aimait bien les jolies filles il se
trouve que il y avait des jeunes des
moins jeunes mais on doit absolument
25 ans voilà mais peut-être même un peu
plus mais on ne parle en aucun cas
d'enfants d'accord mais c'est bien c'est
très bien 14 ans c'est très bien de vous
entendre parce que j'entends beaucoup de
gens qui sont parfois aussi un peu
complotistes et qui disent n'importe
quoi votre avis m'intéresse beaucoup et
j'ai une dernière question je vais pas
vous déranger mais c'est de vous que ça
doit sortir il y a eu cette soi-disant
enquête de la police belge qui avait
enquêté sur votre sœur qui serait née
d'une femme qui avait 14 ans
alors 15 ans 15 ans effectivement
je peux vous dire ce que c'est voilà je
ne suis pas exprimé parce que j'ai parlé
à la maman d'accord et j'ai compris
qu'en réalité julie était une femme
fragile et c'était délicat pour moi de
rentrer en interaction de cette histoire
d'accord mais mais on peut en gros dire
que c'est un manque de vigilance et
est-ce que je peux ce que je peux vous
assurer c'est que mon père ne
connaissait pas l'âge de sa maman quand
il l'a rencontré qui avait été formé
qu'elle parlait quatre langues qu'il
avait tout lieu de croire
qu'elle était beaucoup plus vieille que
ce qu'elle était en réalité et je vous
crois et ça mon but vous poser que des
questions là-dessus parce qu'il y a
tellement de choses que j'aime chez
votre père mais c'était très très
important pour moi aussi que dans ton
nouveau
votre avis à vous parce que c'est votre
père et vous avez donné une petite
comprendre un jour elle lui a donné son
âge elle lui dit mais tu crois que j'ai
quel âge et quand elle lui a dit j'ai 15
ans elle me c'est elle qui me raconte
hein il est devenu blême il l'a regardé
il lui a dit il était folle et qui
finissent en tôle ouais elle est
flamande donc l'atome elle savait pas ce
que ça voulait dire c'est l'argot
français et quand elle me raconte ça ça
s'invente pas voilà donc
j'entends j'ai mes deux dernières
questions et après je vous promets que
si vous voulez venir en plateau on fera
que danser et tout parce que je peux pas
dire parce que votre père il est il est
parce que votre père c'est une icône
il les rend heureux exactement et ben
moi le premier je là ça je l'ai pas
inventé qu'est-ce que je voulais vous
dire deux questions est-ce que votre
sœur vous la voyez ou jamais
non bon et j'ai une dernière question
j'ai une dernière question ok
moyennement agréable et après je vous
jure vous venez en plateau on déjeune
ensemble on est les meilleurs amis il y
a Dany qui a dit dans un documentaire
sur Arte quand je l'ai regardé c'était
quelqu'un de formidable mais très
colérique elle dit un jour je l'ai vu
sortir de l'Olympia des coulisses de
l'Olympia il avait une secrétaire qui
lui tenait son verre d'eau une un miroir
le miroir était trop bas il l'a pris il
lui a éclaté sur la tête c'était un
personnage particulier quand même
j'étais pas là pour
Monsieur j'étais pas là après il était
colérique oui parce que et en fait il
avait trois emplois du temps dans la
même journée il était resta qui était
homme d'affaires et il était artiste et
chacun de ces rôles avaient des
plannings bien chargés et donc bien sûr
que ça rend insupportable le manque
d'attention de rigueur et puis
l'exigence dans laquelle il était il
l'avait parce que dans de la part de
tout son entourage donc ça pouvait
l'excéder par moment mais je débute
taper qui que ce soit avec un miroir sur
la tête j'ai une question de Rome et
déjà je voulais vous remercier parce que
je trouve ça très beau la manière dont
vous défendre de votre père et je trouve
ça très très bien et
des défauts mais bien sûr
mais là on en sait un monstre
régulièrement mais c'est pour ça que je
voulais vous entendre parce que c'est
pas un monstre pour moi du tout je peux
vous promettre que c'est c'est là où
vous avez raison et puis je pense que
quand on a ce niveau d'exigence et qu'on
est premier pour rester premier signe
anxiété tous les jours Laurent a une
question Claude salut c'est leur
fontaine j'ai juste eu une question à te
poser qui a rien rien à voir depuis des
années j'ai envie de voir ton avis sur
le sujet que les droits de comme
d'habitude ont été cédés un milliardaire
français est-ce que c'est vrai ou pas
vrai alors c'est une partie des droits
c'est un catalogue éditorial éditorial
qui a été cédé un consenseur
d'investisseurs français qui est déjà
très bien que la plupart des copyright
aux États-Unis et donc c'est géré par
Emmanuel de burten Michel Duval c'est
une société qui s'appelle because
d'accord c'est des anciens de chez
Virgin musique et j'ai très bien géré et
j'en suis voilà bon mauvais très bien je
vous embête plus avec les c'est je vous
remercie beaucoup d'avoir répondu est-ce
que est-ce que vous acceptez de devenir
un plateau une fois
attention là là si vous venez on fait
juste les chorégraphies je me mets en
Claude
on fait des chorégraphies et on rigole
et on ne parle et on ne parle que de ce
que j'aime de votre père qui a amené les
Claudettes c'est lui qui a fait toutes
les questions
et là on amènera l'intelligence qu'il a
eu d'amener les Claudette d'amener cette
rigueur les chansons toutes les tubes
tous les tubes et merci d'avoir répondu
ces questions
c'est ça qui est vraiment magique mais
exactement merci beaucoup d'avoir
répondu et j'espère que vous allez
accepter de notre invitation parce
qu'elle est très sincère merci à vous
[Applaudissements]